things have been kept some very
hush-hush regarding RuPaul's secret
celebrity drag race which is premiering
this week and since it's the premiere
week I thought it would be fun to try to
guess which celebrities we may see on
the special event series star-studded
competition in herstory the first
celebrity who comes to mind and I would
love to see in drag on the show Andrew
Garfield we know Andrew is a huge fan of
the franchise RuPaul's Drag Race
of course he appeared as a special guest
judge on the series premiere of RuPaul's
Drag Race UK so could Andrew be one of
the secret celebrities the show has been
teasing I think so she's incredibly
charming she's incredibly entertaining
and I want that in a drag girl what a
drag way to take care of me I want to be
able to sit back and and not have to do
any work I want to be taking on a German
[Music]
is another celebrity who would be
incredible on the series Billie's
actually never appeared on RuPaul's Drag
Race in all 12 seasons so this could be
his chance
we know Billy loves to play with fashion
and makeup and I would love to see some
of the Queens put Billy into drag plus
having Billy on RuPaul's secret
celebrity drag race could finally squash
the rumors that RuPaul and Billy don't
get along all right moving on Harry
Styles is someone I would adore to see
on secret celebrity drag lives it would
be incredible not only because Harry
Styles is a huge star but because Harry
has been an ally for the lgbtq+
community and he's not afraid to play
with the sound of his music for his
fashion
[Music]
never come back down will dry brace
finally have drag Kings on the main
stage I certainly hope so especially
with RuPaul's secret celebrity drag race
somebody that I would love to see on the
show is none other then Leslie Jones
of course Leslie was one of the best
guest judges the series has ever had in
all 12 seasons and I think Leslie would
do a fantastic job as a drag king
because she spent oh my god this is
gonna be good someone else I would love
to see on RuPaul's secret celebrity Drag
Race and the timing is right because
they just released a brand new single
Sam Smith no Sam as we know is an
incredible performer they are not afraid
to take risks with their music the
fashion and I think Sam would kill
[Music]
to
[Music]
now another celebrity I would love to
see on the special event series is
Darren Criss Darren has never been on
the show in all 12 seasons so I think
now is his chance and as we've seen in
the past Darren is an incredible
performer
[Applause]
so which celebrities are you hoping to
see on RuPaul's secret celebrity drag
race this week which Queens are you most
looking forward to seeing step back into
that workroom speaking of drag race who
are you rooting for on seasons well let
me know in the comments below oh hey
there if you want more LGBTQ news and
exclusive interviews click subscribe or
watch these videos